[Musique]
une voix famille
hier sur la terrasse d'un bar de
fort-de-france familier le visage lui
l'est beaucoup moins
la familiarité qui est en fait de cette
étonnante faculté degs est ici à
reproduire la voix des artistes dont il
l'a fait après les chansons
scemama
[Musique]
que dire alors lorsque le jeune homme
entonnent les notes de georgia de ray de
chance
[Musique]
c'est la super ambiance
on a adoré tout simplement il est chaud
froid la belle voix très content de
l'entendre illettré il est très bon dans
ce qui fait en tout cas et on
l'encouragé à continuer les voix se
foutrait qui nous berce et surtout après
le travail ça nous permet de nous
relaxer
mais qui ici a aussi son répertoire
propre des chansons qu'il compose et
écrit lui même comme ma vision tiré de
l'album du même nom
[Musique]
je dormais d'origine sainte lucienne
arrivée en martinique à l'âge de 7 ans
il passe aussi dix années de sa vie en
france où il se fait connaître sur
internet
dans une vidéo captée par le passage et
d'autres où il chantait aveugle de
naissance il a fait de son handicap en
atout qui résiste aujourd'hui aux
railleries dont il est parfois victime
aux traits d'humour aussi je suis non
voyants complètement mais bon ça aurait
pu être pire bête noire pour moi c'est
une force mais aussi un atout parce que
le fait d'être non-voyant samassa m'a
permis d'être au delà au delà de
l'apparence et au delà de ce que les
gens ils peuvent penser
[Musique]
celle ci est également musicien ce soir
il est venu sans instrument mais qu'à
cela ne tienne le jeune homme n'en n'a
pas fini d'étonner like to bill
commandes
[Musique]
dans ce